[Music]
phone guards are usually pretty harmless
not in the hands of a master of disaster
[Music]
whoa ooh take that camp with over 8
million hits this is the most
destructive foam dart gun ever
let's dart over to Alicia Oh Italy to
meet Jia Co the creator of this deadly
dart gun me and a bunch of friends we're
talking about like how fast can a dart
go and I was actually the one in the
corner like really seriously thinking
about testing it the first time I shot
it was way more powerful than I expected
actually I never found the dart anymore
I think it exploded somewhere
how Jacko's cannon causing chaos the dot
exits the gun at an astonishing 1,800
miles per hour or two thousand nine
hundred kilometers per hour that's twice
the speed of sound even though the dart
is very light traveling at such a high
speed means it has an enormous amount of
energy 340 joules that happens to be a
porter the amount of energy of a rifle
shot
this is my cannon the power comes from
compressed air that I store in this tank
then I put my dark in it when I'm ready
I press the bottom and the magic happens
to one to get these dark up to speed
Jocko is using the power of a repurposed
oxygen tank which has gas pressurized at
400 pounds per square inch which is 27
times the pressure of normal air when
jackal opens the valve the high-pressure
air inside the tank wants to equalize
with the lower pressure air outside and
the only way you can do that is push the
dart out and keep on moving I think
there's something really satisfying
about destroying things and I guess
doing with a toy that it's meant to you
know for kids it's even more interesting
for building a foam Guard cannon that's
definitely not Charles play Jocko you're
a master of disaster